and then he's going to give us a some
tips out saying tips on boxing we've got
a very very very high-tech piece of
equipment over here so if you'd like to
come with me it's over here
[Applause]
longest okay don't turn it on
it's all it's all now oh okay
there we go so I hit that yeah okay
it didn't talk this afternoon what's
happened to it
[Music]
are you serious any tips cause you're in
high heels should I take him off no I'm
not sure he's talking to me
we run ups
if you want to take them off I wasn't
even thinking about run up it's Rachel
gopher no no don't don't take your shoes
off just like a girl in these
competitive
[Applause]
[Applause]
wanna go first Rachel you want to go oh
I don't mind I just feel like I could
hit okay you see the key
any other advice are you left or
right-handed right right so you know
right leg back so you really get the
whole back okay miss just to get it goes
away you go boom it goes back up okay
okay I honestly mine was so bad so let's
see what Rachel gets and then on the
side one way to do it
[Applause]
leg forwards yeah yeah you in range
though are you and range I don't know
like should I find out is that come
forward a bit come forward a bit because
you want to remember your aim is to
punch through the bag through so I want
to go like that
yes I like that
[Applause]
183
okay here we go
okay we have what do I need - 182 - Pete
180
there's no telling what you don't care
and then you do yeah
come on just have a staredown with him
laughs first okay
[Applause]
No
[Laughter]
[Applause]
five nine four feet here we go here we
go
[Applause]
Anthony Joshua
I'm still going okay I tell you what was
yours eight eight B was three thousand
six seven two wasn't what six seven two
six three two so if you don't beat back
so tightly okay okay here we go this
technique adieu the world
[Applause]
[Music]